adrian hauser after a couple of uh poor
starts back to back trying to get things
back on track yeah earned an average in
the month of may not real good two
points higher than his era in the month
of april last two starts have been rough
3-2 to fam right back to him
one up and one down to start hauser's
outing and the busted bat to go along
with it
sent the game to extra innings
sends this one out to left very playable
for jackie bradley jr for the second out
of the unit
that's the way they play today jam job
ground ball hit to kesten hira
cronenworth is retired and so are the
padres on the mound for the padres is
ryan weathers now the 21 year old making
his 11th appearance six start on the
season he is an excellent two-in-one
record with a 1.48
era 11th appearance of the year sixth
start
and a grounder to shorten tatis
low throw and it is dug out by hosmer
and here he comes and that one is lying
to left this is going to get to the
corner in a hurry
and adamus will cruise in the second
with a standing one out double
[Applause]
on the ground to third base and twisting
is kim fires to first for the out
runners on the corners for casting hira
swinging a miss and now he is out of it
back to the slider again first strikeout
ends the first scoreless after one
curveball can be a big pitch for him at
times
strikes out fernando tatis with that
heavy sinker
i mean exactly where you want it under
the bat
[Music]
hosmer in the right center is he going
to hang up for garcia yes nice play avi
garcia had him played perfectly
another payoff
struck him out good change-up adrian
hauser and an inning plus for weathers
a ball that is fair this time cut off by
kim on the run and in time some fancy
footwork on the other side
for eric hosmer
002 pitch strike three on the outside
corner weathers makes quick work of
bradley jr and the screen's now you
really can't even see him this is in to
left but out there is fernando tatis
junior
the old days
carratini chased that change up
third strikeout for adrian hauser and
needed to wind down
weather swings and misses at a breaking
ball he's going to
lightly jog and
freeze halfway up
and a fly ball headed to short right
garcia coming in full born it's going to
fall
base hit for tommy pham first base
runner to reach for the padres there he
goes
and a fly ball sent foul and was there
catcher interference yes there was
so getting first base would be
cronenworth
runners take off hauser steps off
they've got fam caught
maurice is going to run him down what
are they doing on the bases you got
tatis up you got hosmer on deck i mean
they're messing around on the bases two
on two out brown ball to short adamus
has it flips to gorillas covering the
bag they get the force on tatis one
extra pitch for hauser and he gets out
of it
deep short
and tatis throws him out for the first
out of the fourth inning
this one is swung on and popped up
shallow right center
it will be o'grady the right fielder
getting underneath of it to make the
catch runner will go and now the 3-2 to
uris has swung on and missed strike
three and the fifth k of the day for
ryan weathers
getting ready this one popped up to
willy adams
3-1 delivery is swinging a pop-up this
is playable too
and it is going to be
robertson yes
so for one
and a grounder through the third baseman
robertson kicked off him and into foul
ground kim's headed for second base
he'll get their standing
so mateo will bat for weathers payoff
pitch to matteo
get on the ground one hot fielded by
adamus throw to first got him
what a play by luis urias
used as a long man at times for the
padres but up and down
ground ball to the right side and it's
tatis in the shift who throws out
jackie bradley jr
one up one down and daniel robertson
line drive left center field it's got
gap written all over and it's off the
wall
robertson digs into second base with a
one-out double
in the air to left field fam
will make the catch bill of a cat pie
for out number two
willie adams coming to the plate he's
doubled and struck out there goes kane
swinging the ground ball shark he hits a
fair ball diving stabbed by kim it'll
bring a run home
one nothing brewers kim may have saved
another run from scoring see if they can
break it open here with avi garcia
swinging a smash to the hold diving stab
and gets by
to tease junior throw coming home way
off target
he threw it past carratini
two-nothing milwaukee
biggest at-bat of the game right now
fernando tatis the tying run at the
plate
bam at second two away down two in the
sixth and the o one is just work to left
field no chance for bradley this time
that'll skip up against the fence on two
hops fam into score tatis into second
rbi double fernando tatis jr and it's a
two to one game here in the top of the
sixth it's now hosmer with two outs
runner up
osmer hits it in the air to left field
and deep back goes jackie bradley jr
it's gone a two-run home run for eric
hosmer opposite field and the padres
take a 3-2 lead
home run number five of the year for
hosmer
they came into the inning trailing by
two not anymore well now he got first
and second nobody out lorenzo cain at
the plate
wong takes off swinging a miss throw to
third not in time yelich follows double
steal
it's second and third kane strikes out
both runners in scoring position
so here's adamus the batter
high fly
deep
[Applause]
picks the perfect time
for his first home run as a brewer it
was the breaking ball
and he hung it and willie didn't miss it
tatis the tying run here in the eighth
tatis hits it in the air to shallow left
and that's going to fall behind adamson
coming around from second base is pro
far he'll score and it's a one run game
as fernando drives in another run
runners on the corners and one out pinch
hitter manny machado about to come up
again a way outside target set by
narvaez pitch is lined over the head of
the second baseman wong and into right
center field it's going to roll all the
way to the wall fernando has scored to
tie it hosmer is on his way here's the
relay to the plate and it is in time
gotta hit the cutoff man they were able
to do that and then adamus able to do
the rest he throws a strike to narayans
and now omar narvaez last chance for
brewers to win it in regulation
lied right into the shift into
cronenworth and the perfect spot
osmer smash and no catch
race to the bag and he wins it two outs
now for jackie bradley jr a one
swing and a fly ball hit to right myers
on the track it's off the wall
a game winner for jackie bradley jr
and the brewers win it by a final of six
five and ten